PROFESSOR: So we
figured out that you
can get the book stack,
the overhang of the books,
to be half the harmonic sum.
With n books, you
can get out Hn over 2
where Hn is this harmonic
sum, or harmonic number.
The question is, how are we
going to estimate or calculate
what this sum is?
Now it turns out there is no
simple formula for exactly
what this sum is, but there
is a simple formula that
estimates it quite accurately.
And we get the estimation by
bounding the sum by integrals.
And so let's look at this
integral method for estimating
sums.
Remember what I wanted
was the sum of 1 plus 1/2
plus 1/3 down to 1 over n.
So let's form some unit
width rectangles of heights
equal to the amount that I want.
So here's a rectangle of height
1, rectangle of height 1/2,
rectangle of height 1/3.
I'm going out here, if
you actually count to 8,
but let's propose that
this is a height 1 over n.
And what I know is that the
total area of these rectangles
is actually equal to
the number that I want.
The total area of
these rectangles
is the harmonic number.
And I'm interested in a lower
bound for Hn, because I want
to know how far I can get out.
I want a tight lower bound.
It says Hn is larger
than a certain amount.
That's the amount that I'm sure
that I can stack out in books.
So the way I'm going to get a
lower bound on this number Hn
is by looking at
this curve that goes
through the corners
of the rectangles.
And if you check it, that
curve is 1 over x plus 1.
That is, the point here is--
when x is 0, I'm at 1 over 1.
When x is 1, I'm at 1/2, the
height of the second rectangle,
and so on.
So 1 over x plus
1 is a curve that
is strictly below the boundaries
of all these rectangles.
That means that the area under 1
over x plus 1 going from 0 to n
is a lower bound on Hn,
because it's a lower bound
on the area of the rectangles.
So Hn equals the area
of the rectangles.
It's greater than the
area of 1 over x plus 1,
which of course is equal
to the integral from 0
to n of 1 over x plus 1,
which shifting variables is
the same as the integral from
1 to n plus 1 of 1 over x
dx, which of course we know is
a natural logarithm of n plus 1.
So there we have it.
The overhang that you need
for three books, which
is Bn greater than
or equal to 3,
means that Hn has to be
greater than or equal to 6.
So by this estimate,
I need log of n
plus 1 greater
than or equal to 6
in order to get three books
out, that the back end
of the top book is two books
past the edge of the table
and the right end of
the furthest out book
is three book lengths past
the edge of the table.
So my bound tells me
that I need n books such
that log of n plus 1 is
greater than or equal to 6.
Well, exponentiating both
sides, the right-hand side
becomes e to the 6th.
And I figure out
that as long as n
is greater than or equal to e to
the 6th minus 1 books-- rounded
up, of course, because there's
only-- you can't have fractions
of a book-- you get an
estimate that with 403 books,
I can actually get my stack to
stick out three book lengths
past the edge of the table.
Well if you do the
actual calculation
instead of the
estimate, it turns out
that 227 books are enough.
So this estimate's a little off.
But for our
purposes, it tells us
a dramatic fact, which is that
we know that log of n plus 1
approaches infinity as
n approaches infinity.
And that means that,
with enough books,
I can get out as far as I want.
You tell me how many book
lengths you want to be out,
I'll use the log n formula
to calculate how many books I
need to get that far out.
So here's an example of
some students in the class
some years ago decided to
do this as an experiment.
Now when we used to
do this in class,
we first tried to do it
with the big, heavy textbook
that we used.
And we kept trying to get
them to balance and go out
over the edge of
the table, and they
failed, because it turns
out that textbooks are heavy
and they compress.
They're not the rigid
rectangular cross sections
that our model was based on.
But CD cases work very well.
They are more rigid.
They don't compress easily,
and they're very lightweight
so that they don't
cause problems
with distortions because
of the size of the stack.
And so you can actually get CD
cases to stick out pretty far.
This is an example where
it's 43 CD cases high,
and the top four
cases are completely
past the edge of the table.
The leftmost edge is about
1.81 or 1.91 case lengths
past the table.
There's another view of it from
the guy who made the stack.
And of course, they were
right on the edge of stability
in trying to get the CDs to
stick out as far as possible.
So if you notice these
little spaces there,
in terms of the balancing,
it's really just
on the brink of falling over.
If you sneeze at it, it'll tip.
But if you don't sneeze
at it, it's stable,
and you get the top
CD out that far.
So while we're at it, let's
get an upper bound for Hn.
We just got a lower bound
of Hn, but the same kind
of logic of using an
integral will give you
an upper bound for Hn.
What I do now is I run a
curve from the upper right
corners of the rectangles.
And that curve is
simply 1 over x.
So an upper bound for
the harmonic number
Hn is the area under 1 over
x out to n plus this 1.
And so I get an upper bound that
says that the harmonic number
Hn is less than
the integral from 1
to n of 1 over x dx plus 1, or
it's equal to 1 plus log of n.
So combining those
two bounds that I
got by looking at a curve
that's a lower bound on the area
and a curve that's an
upper bound on the area
and integrating, I discover
that Hn is bracketed
between the natural
log of n plus 1 and 1
plus the natural log of n.
Now these two numbers, log of
n plus 1 and 1 plus log of n,
are very close, and they get
closer and closer as n grows.
So it turns out that what
we can say pretty accurately
is that Hn is asymptotically
equal to log n.
It's approximately
And the precise definition
of this tilde symbol
that I've highlighted in magenta
is called asymptotically equal.
And the general definition
of asymptotically equal,
that Hn is asymptotically
equal to log n,
is that a function f
of n is asymptotically
equal to a function g of n when
the limit of their quotient
goes to 1.
That is to say, as a
multiplicative factor,
each is within a constant one
of the other in the limit.
1 plus epsilon of-- 1 plus
or minus epsilon of gn
is going to bracket
fn, and vice versa.
Asymptotic equivalents,
or asymptotic equality.
Let's do an example.
So the remark would
be, for example,
that n squared plus
n is asymptotically
equal to n squared.
Why?
Well let's look at the limit
as n approaches infinity of n
squared plus n over n squared.
It's the same as
simplifying algebraically
the limit of 1 over 1 plus n.
As n approaches infinity,
that term goes to zero.
Sure enough, the limit is
1, and so these two terms
are asymptotically equal.
The idea of asymptotically
equal is that all we care about
is the high order term.
The low order terms
will disappear,
and we're looking at
the principal term that
controls the growth rate of the
functions when we look at them
up to asymptotic equivalence.
So let's step back
for just a moment
and generalize what
we've done here
with estimating
the harmonic sum.
There's a general method called
the integral method where,
in this particular
case, suppose we
have a function f, the
positive real valued function
that's weakly decreasing,
like 1 over x.
Then let's let S be the sum
from i equals 1 to n of f of i.
So I was interested where
f of x was 1 over x,
and I wanted the sum
from 1 over-- 1 to n of 1
over i, which was the
nth harmonic number.
And I was comparing that
to the integral from 1 to n
of f of x, or 1 over
x in our example.
So if I is the integral and
S is the sum that I want,
what we can conclude really
is that, in general, the sum
is bracketed between the
integral plus the first term
of f of 1 in the sum,
and the integral plus
the last term of the sum.
Remember, f is weakly
decreasing, so f of n
is smaller than f of 1.
There's a similar theorem
actually, just reverse f of 1
and f of n, to use
an integral estimate
to get a bound on a weakly
increasing function.
And that gives us a
general tool for estimating
the growth rate of sums.